[موسيقى]
اقترحت الكلية التمثيلية بالأمس أن الديمقراطيين يفعلون
ذلك لمجرد أنهم لا يحبون
الرجل الذي أعتقد أن الرئيس جبان
عندما يتعلق الأمر بمساعدة أطفالنا
الذين يخشون عنف السلاح ، وأعتقد أنه
رائع  عندما لا يتعامل مع مساعدة
الحالمين لدينا رغم أنهم كانوا
فخورين جدًا ، أعتقد أنه ينكر
الدستور بشأن أزمة المناخ ،
لكن هذا يتعلق بالانتخابات ،
فهذا يتعلق بالانتخاب الذي سيخوضه في
الانتخابات وهذا يتعلق
بدستور  الولايات المتحدة والحقائق التي
تؤدي إلى انتهاك الرئيس
لقسم اليمين ، وككاثوليكي أنا
مستاء من استخدامك لكلمة كره في
جملة تخاطبني ، فأنا لا أكره
أي شخص نشأته بطريقة
مليئة  قلب مليء بالحب ودائمًا
ما أصلي من أجل الرئيس وما زلت
أصلي من أجل الرئيس وأدعو
الرئيس طوال الوقت حتى لا تعبث
معي عندما يتعلق الأمر بكلمات كهذه